when I talk about boundaries that I've had to set with family members
after having children a lot of people think they're
like crazy things that I have requested from my family members
but in my opinion they are really common sense things
for example or I'll give you all a couple examples
um we have to leave functions for our child's bedtime
this to me
doesn't seem like a crazy thing
it just means that the priority is making sure our child goes down
at the regular bedtime because if you've had a tough sleeper
you know that bedtime is bedtime
and if someone doesn't respect that
or someone tries to make you feel guilty for that
or someone tries to push you to stay longer
oh they're gonna be fine
don't make it such a big deal
you you shouldn't have to leave
like you're being a helicopter parent
that's not respectful of a
your priority as a parent
or b your boundary of like no
I already told you I have to leave at this time
another completely reasonable example for us
was that everybody had to get vaccinated before they came to see our child
and this was even pre covid
so like
this is 2014 for with our first
as per the pediatrician's recommendation
all visitors for a Newborn had to be vaccinated for flu
and had to make sure they had an updated Tdap
we got a little bit of pushback that I was not expecting
and that was one of those hard boundary lines where I was like no
if you are not vaccinated
you're not coming to see the baby
so again when I'm talking about setting boundaries with family
especially surrounding having children
becoming a parent having them and their safety and well being being a priority
there is no wiggle room
but that doesn't mean that these boundaries are anything that is um
or should be unexpected or not easy to a abide by
I know a lot of people have the take shoes off when you come in the house
because my baby's crawling around
or just like
general cleanliness it's simple things like that
when you get pushed back for that
you start to question the level of respect that that person has for you
or what boundaries you're gonna put in place
or the way you're gonna navigate that relationship going forward